coluche de son vrai nom michel colucci
et nl 28 octobre 1944 à paris il était
le fils d'un peintre en bâtiment c'était
l'artiste incontesté du route du rire et
de l'humour décapant
il avait fait ses débuts au café de la
gare un café théâtre avec miou-miou
patrick dewaere et gérard lanvin
notamment l'artiste coluche l'homme à la
salopette à rayures bleues france roche
quand on disait coluche le public criait
ce soir le nom de coluche fait pleurer
oublier sa provocation c'est mon vitriol
ce visage lunaire ce cor anglais sont
sans vie déguisés en femmes comme à la
cérémonie de son mariage avec le luron
il avait monté il ya moins d'un mois
l'escalier d'honneur du festival de
cannes car malgré ou à cause de ses 15
ans de succès il raffolait des farces et
des déguisements en salopette éclatante
sur scène ou à la télévision en veston
rose
il était apparu l'an dernier en général
névrosée dans le fou de guerre les armes
et chaque matin nous avons son réveil
d'une demi-heure de manière à ce qu'on
fur et à mesure vous habituels pu dormir
que deux ou trois heures oui le soleil
et avis
l'échec de ce film tourné en italie et
celui de dagobert l'avait poussé à
revenir à la télévision à la radio où il
retrouvera le même succès que pour tchao
pantin couronné par un césar c'est de la
drogue quoi sans joie joie
ça commence par ajoie on sait comment ça
finit ils étaient contents ce jour-là
coluche l'amuseur d'être reconnu comme
un grand acteur
c'était le rêve exaucé du jeune michel
colucci fils d'un peintre en bâtiment
qui après avoir tâté de douze ou treize
petits métiers avait été un des
fondateurs du café de la gare où il
avait fait entrer une petite vendeuse
qui l'avait baptisé du nom coca c'est
gentil de miu miu
la carrière cinématographique de coluche
fut faite de hauts et de bas de bons et
de mauvais film mais sur scène il avait
toujours trop
et provocateur dérangeant à la limite
dangereuse du trop méconnu jamais
dépassé les bornes
comme les limites de vitesse en rodéo
automobile en moto ou dans le show
business il allait vite
à 41 ans il avait vécu 16 ans de succès
à divorce une dépression et récolté
beaucoup d'amis qui peuplent et jour et
nuit sa maison ouverte à tous ceux qui
avaient besoin de ne pas être seul lui
aussi aime à la foule celle de son
public
des témoins de ces farces ou ceux pour
qui réinvente and radio ati conformiste
devinette quel est l'endroit où les
femmes sont le plus frisé en afrique